in a groundbreaking trial a woman is
found guilty of involuntary manslaughter
for sending texts encouraging her
boyfriend to commit suicide the case
raised questions about whether words can
kill aaron Moriarity of 48 hours was in
the Massachusetts courtroom for the
verdict it's good having reviewed the
evidence and applied the law there to
now find you guilty the defendant 20
year-old Michelle Carter lost her
composure as judge Lawrence Moniz
announces verdict in the death of her
friend Conrad Roy who died in a Kmart
parking lot nearly three years ago from
carbon monoxide poisoning the judge
found that a stream of text messages and
phone calls from Carter persuaded
18-year old Roy to take his own life
even as he had doubts his Court finds
that instructing mr. Roy to get back in
the truck
constituted wanton and reckless conduct
by miss Cara in the last week of Roy's
life Carter sent dozens of text messages
urging him to kill himself all part of
what prosecutors say was an attempt to
gain sympathy and attention from
classmates you're ready and prepared all
you have to do is turn the generator on
and be free and happy but it was this
text from Carter to her friend Sam
Boardman sent two months after Roy's
death it sealed her fate I could have
stopped him I was on the phone with him
and he got out of the car because it was
working and he got scared and I told him
to get back in the defense argued that
Roy would have taken his life anyway he
had a history of depression in suicide
attempts
social anxiety depression it's
controlling me
prosecutor Cady Rayburn there are no
winners here today two families have
been torn apart and will be affected by
this for years to come Michelle Carter
was 17 when Conrad Roy died and in
essence was tried as an adult which
means she faces up to 20 years in prison
she's out on bail until she's sentenced
for CBS this morning Saturday on Erin
Moriarty in Taunton Massachusetts